traditionnel briefing de départ jour j
pour toutes les participantes engagé sur
ce deuxième raid united ladies loire des
femmes unies contre le cancer du sein
l'idée de ce défi nature vient d'un
médecin de saumur qui sait qu'on est
plus forts ensemble
les organisateurs sont là pour motiver
les troupes
le vivre ensemble pendant pendant quatre
jours c'est pas évident c'est sur un
milieu naturel on va faire des bivouacs
on va dormir en fête au bord de la
rivière et c'est pas forcément en fait
idéal pour la fatigue et il faut bien
voilà que chacun y mette du sien pour
arriver en fait vivre une belle aventure
30 de femmes concernées par la maladie
quatre bateaux c'est le début de la
grande aventure
c'est génial on à l'excitation qui est
là on est super équipe quatre jours pour
parcourir 250 km entre orléans et les
ponts de cé en maine et loire
en dépit du faible niveau du fleuve
royal nos championnes progresse toujours
dans la bonne humeur
je trouve que c'est l'expérience la plus
magnifique qui soit en dragon boat ou
ans et neuf d'aller sur la loire un
fleuve qui est sauvage et devoirs elle
nous accepte et de voir tous ces animaux
tous ces oiseaux le silence
on revit pas de pardon de tous et les
pales sont très très bien parce que dans
quelques mois on a quelques centimètres
ce n'est pas beaucoup
une belle épopée internationale qui
traverse actuellement la région entre
loire et loir et cher et touraine